Halloween almost opponents getting
excited about Halloween I am fun time
how about you Andy you are you ready for
Halloween
yeah I get a lot of trick-or-treaters in
our neighborhood so it should be fun oh
that's cool
we do that too what are you gonna give
out this year you know Conan I'm so glad
you asked
as someone who only makes $7 an hour I
need to watch my budget and since buying
candy for the entire neighborhood can
get pretty pricey I by Sanderson sampler
Sanderson sampler is a much cheaper
alternative to buying top-shelf candy
and has a lot of great candy brands that
kind of sort of taste like the real
thing
brands like Snickers melty way char
Colston choux twacks
star burbs and an ends to to troll
almond boy sour pooch pups Twizzlers 3
Mujahideen's milk buds
Herschel's kisses skittles Tobler een
finger butter and ruses peanut butter
cops
I gotta say I'm sick No
and I gotta say those all sound terrible
uh-huh no no no they're great and kids
won't know the difference
either watch this trick or treat
there you go buddy have a Snickers ah
Burns Sanderson sampler they'll never
know
go get out of here
did you just tell that kid to get lost
yes I told him to act like it's good get
lost kid